The Marvel Cinematic Universe might look very
different had the God of Thunder not been
put through the wringer.
Screenwriters Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely explained that they had to change
their plans due to the radical reinvention
of Thor in director Taika Waititi's ​Thor:
Ragnarok.​
Fans of the MCU know very well that Waititi
essentially rehabilitated the character of
Thor after his somewhat lackluster portrayal
in the series prior to Ragnarok.
While there were always humorous undertones
to the God of Thunder, Waititi tapped into
star Chris Hemsworth's comedic chops to give
us a Thor who was just as quippy as his fellow
Avengers.
"But if I'm being honest, when it comes to
fighting evil beings, he is very powerful."
"Banner is powerful too."
"Is he, though?"
The hero's newly comedic personality felt
very different to his rather dour demeanor
in other MCU films, which meant that early
drafts of Infinity War needed to be adjusted
to accommodate it.
"Remember, we were inheriting a Thor from
Ragnarok who was very well and radically re-toned
from the previous Avengers movies."
According to Markus and McFeely, they actually
had to fly in Hemsworth and Waititi to make
sure that the Odinson's characterization made
sense going from Thor: Ragnarok to Avengers:
Infinity War.
But Waititi didn't just tweak the Thunder
God's characterization - he put the poor guy
through the kind of narrative gauntlet that
few Marvel characters have had to endure,
forcing him to experience more loss in a single
film than he ever had before.
Markus and McFeely saw in this an opportunity
to portray Thor in a novel, almost shocking
way.
In Avengers: Infinity War, the Thunder God
is obviously still hurting from the events
of Ragnarok, and in that film's opening, he's
forced to witness the murder of his adopted
brother Loki, as well as his friend Heimdall
at the hands of Thanos.
During a later conversation with Rocket, Thor
seems withdrawn, unsure of himself, insecure,
even depressed.
That continues to the end of the film, in
which Thor makes a crucial error, failing
to immediately kill Thanos, allowing the Mad
Titan to snap away half of all life in the
universe.
The failure nearly breaks the Thunder God,
and when we see him in Avengers: Endgame,
he's despondent enough over it to kill a defenseless
Thanos in the film's opening moments.
Markus explained:
"In Thor: Ragnarok, he loses his kingdom,
his father, his sister, and his eyeball.
We just thought about what would happen if
any one of us sustained this loss and horror.
You would get incredibly depressed and retreat
from the world.
That is a comedic performance with a lot of
pain behind it."
If Waititi hadn't put Thor through the ringer
in Ragnarok, it's safe to say that Markus
and McFeely's interpretation of the character
would have been very different.
Considering how instrumental Thor's failure
and subsequent breakdown are to the narrative
of Infinity War and Endgame, it's possible
that inheriting a steadier, more confident
Odinson might have changed the entire story
that Markus and McFeely were crafting.
For that matter, the dour, kingly Thor of
his first two solo films almost certainly
wouldn't have made the choice he did at the
conclusion of Endgame to leave New Asgard
in the hands of Valkyrie and head out to go
on interstellar adventures with the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
This development seems likely to affect the
MCU's overarching narrative for years to come;
writer/director James Gunn's upcoming Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3 will certainly have to
address it, and Thor's decision to leave Earth
behind is also certain to play into the story
of 2021's Thor: Love and Thunder.
The latter film will see Waititi return to
the franchise to showcase Thor's former flame
Jane Foster picking up the hammer to become
the Mighty Thor.
Indeed, it's easy to make the case that with
Thor: Ragnarok, Waititi didn't just reinvent
the Thor franchise - he shook up the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
It's also pretty amazing that Markus and McFeely
were able to incorporate the adjustments while
also constructing the most complex narrative
the franchise has ever seen, and still crack
the story for the highest-grossing movie in
history.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.